il nous reste trois minutes pour parler
de cette voie qui est en passe d'être
adopté alors fini l'a fait c'est
peut-être un vote du sénat doit rendre
ce texte définitif il prévoit
l'interdiction des châtiments corporels
le texte est consensuel du moins au
niveau des parlementaires qui l'ont
votée à la quasi unanimité mais il fait
aussi débat beaucoup de parents
continuant de penser qu'une petite gifle
ou une tape sur les fesses ne peut être
comparé à des violences on écoute juste
la députée à l'origine de ce texte mots
de petits députés du modem
c'est un texte à portée symbolique
pédagogique qui qui sera lu dans les
mariages lors des mariages en fait
puisqu'il y aura un petit alinéa qui
sera rajouté un article du code civil
sur l'autorité parentale et qui
stipulera qui indiquera que l'autorité
parentale s'exerce sans violence
physique et psychologique
alors il ya sans doute un peu de marche
parce que selon l'observatoire je ne
savais pas que ça existait
l'observatoire de la violence éducative
ordinaire c'est son nom 85% des parents
utilisent encore la fessée ou la gifle
comme pratique éducative
olivier ravanello le texte une bonne
chose ça fixe un cadre après où l'état
se mêle de ce qui ne le regarde pas
je trouve que ce que ce serait bien que
moment en effet d'une cérémonie
officielle dans une mairie on rappelle
aussi que dans une famille potentiel
puisque mon du mariage
en général cette famille et potentiels
l'enfant va avoir une place et qu'il
doit aussi être respectées au même titre
que les époux qui qui s'engagent
mutuellement au respect et à l'entr'aide
et ensuite je trouve que tous ceux qui
qui montent sur leurs grands chevaux aux
rats on pourra pas on rentre dans notre
vie privée et puis une petite claque sur
la mince a jamais fait de mal c'est pas
du tout ce que dit le texte
donc chacun en fait projet tes fantasmes
des choses il ya clairement une volonté
de dire l'usagé de la violence comme
système éducatif n'est pas tolérable
et ça c'est une réalité je pense que
tous autour de la table dans le partage
qui après dans un moment d'agacement
vous avez un geste malheureux que la
plupart des parents à commencer par moi
regrette dans l'heure qui suit voilà je
ça va continuer
sonne dans la rue north a légalement le
droit d'aller vous dénoncez au
commissariat parce qu'il vous aura vu
mettre une tape sur les fesses de voeux
de votre enfant parce que ils traversent
pas au moment où le feu passe au vert
enfin tout ça en fin de compte est un
faux débat où chacun projette des choses
en revanche il ya une réalité c'est
qu'on est encore dans un pays où il ya
des gens qui considèrent que la violence
utilisée de manière très froide
moi je les ai vus j'ai vu un cousin se
faire élevé de cette manière là à dire
que très calmement son père lui disait
quand il avait des mauvaises notes
mais qui pouvait se tourner et sortait
sa ceinture et très calmement il lui
mettez leur un coup de ceinture ça c'est
un système éducatif qui utilisent la
violence et qui n'est pas tolérable
c'est bien que cela vous le rappelle une
loi qui effectivement permet de fixer ce
cadre et de rappeler un certain nombre
de principes à l'écrit non moi je pense
que c'est grotesque quand j'essaie de
loi symbolique pédagogique pour changer
ce qui se passe dans la tête des gens et
dans la vie des gens et les sondes sont
absurdes
ce qui me choque c'est qu'on met
justement tout de même qu'à y conte mais
ces violences dont vous parlez et c'est
vrai que l'arsenal pénal en matière de
violence faite aux enfants de vraies
violences de ce que vous dites des
enfants secouer tout ça on met ça sur le
même plan qu'une fessée aucune connu
qu'une paire de claques c'est c'est
grotesque et ces essais ne pas se donner
les moyens de lutter contre les brèches
les vrais les vrais sujets et donc on
mélange tout et à la fin on off on se
donne bonne conscience
à la fin on ne fait évidemment rien
parce que c'est beau ce qu'il y aura ça
qu il y aura eu un enfant donc battu de
moins dans ce pays y en aura pas un de
moins
simplement on sera content qu'on va
changer les gens et qu'on va changer les
mentalités
offrez mieux de s'attaquer à mon sens
utile aux vraies questions que de
s'attaquer à ça ce n'est pas
incompatible et de son fait on confond
la loi et la morale il faut absolument
rappelé comme vous l'avez dit qu' on ne
doit pas battre les enfants de manière
systématique et autres ça c'est très
important maintenant ce texte ne prévoit
d'abord aucune sanction si ce n'est
en matière civile ce texte est vraiment
la caractéristique même de ce qu'on
appelle un texte inutile nous sommes
victimes en france d'une inflation
législative
il ya des textes pour tous il est
totalement inutile il faut en revanche
axée sur l'éducation la pédagogie à
l'égard des parents et ce serait juste
sur un point d'accord avec vous ça ne
fait pas de mal lors du mariage de leur
dire que le but du jeu ce n'est pas de
battre les enfants s'ils tentaient qu'
il ya des parents qui puisse imaginer
que les enfers c'est le goût du jour ce
jeune femme en général se marient
personnes se dit que l'homme a en tête
que toute façon il va battre sa femme et
le nombre de femmes battues et considère
alors c'est bien parce qu'il est à
présent très bien vous entendre sur ce
sujet texte totalement inutiles disait
que si j'apprends qu'on va traiter le
sujet mon réflexe spontané le même que
tout ce qu'ils disent mais qu'est ce
qu'on vient nous casser les pieds mais
qu'est ce que c'est encore faire le
neutron législatif une loi qui est
symbolique externat et puis je prépare
un peu l'émission et après je suis
impressionné d'apprendre que 50 % des
parents utilisent la violence physique
aux fins frappe n'est pas pas la
maltraitance mais donne deux claques ou
fessée à des enfants de moins de 2 des
enfants de moins de deux ans ce que
j'ignorais évidemment totalement
j'apprends que la commission qu'est ce
que j'apprends que la commission au
sénat a voté le texte à l'unanimité je
me dit le sénateur quand même son bilan
sérieux et puis à toutes les tendances
qui sont présentes et donc les gens qui
ont étudié le problème pense qu'il ya eu
et il y tenait à ce que dans le code
civil en puis s'inscrire au mariage au
moment du mariage la célébration du
mariage rappel de cette exigence
et du coup alors que je n'étais pas
convaincu je le suis devenu voulait être
devenu alors ce qu'en pensent nos
internautes sont un quart 25% exactement
à sauver l'interdiction de la fessée
donc large majorité estime que cette loi
n'a pas lieu d'être